do you know that world's leading pharma  company gsk says their antibody cocktail  is going to be efficient against omicron  shot review map which is developed by  gsk and veer tested on lab animals like  hamster and they are found they found it  to be quite efficient  when our body is infected by virus our  immune system generates antibodies  against the virus and thereby  neutralizing the virus and eliminating  it now if we provide this antibody  cocktail from outside it should be also  working  and sautrovimab is essentially an  antibody cocktail  now this is effect effective on viruses  which has mutations  very similar to the omicron variant so  it should also work on omicron  right now clinical trials are awaited  but it has been tested on hamster and it  works so fingers crossed  don't forget to subscribe